[Music]
what are you gonna do in the future to
avoid them backstage I'm definitely
gonna be more conscious where my hands
are
yeah that's pretty good idea Bonner he
and Sharna told me that they plan to put
hand gate in their rearview mirror
tonight but one thing that just will not
go away are those rumors that they have
become more than just dance partner
[Music]
look at me people at home are letting us
know that they sense a little spark
between the two of you look really
chemistry yeah I think people have said
that at all still this pair insists
they're both totally single
you're single one on personal all
available full-on yes I am absolutely
saying go about the chemistry between
the Australian beauty and the pro bull
rider is undeniable what it's hard to
believe they met for the first time just
three weeks ago you have to be okay with
getting close and check out who Bonner
can't help but look at when I ask this
question what are you looking for in a
woman like a girlfriend I look for it's
just like this is one who's genuine and
that's humble you know that has a lot of
Drive I much like her I know you guys
are focused on the competition right now
but you know maybe down the road baller
would you ever date Charlotte I mean if
I don't yell at him every day my finger
would I'm gonna have to you know see
where that one goes and take that into
consideration
we'll leave it all a mystery now Sharla
what's your day partner it depends on
how well he does his dance moves
I'm kidding it's listen who knows
another Asian Santa Monica
[Music]
you